hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday March 18 2008 eh what's going
on oh what's up with you what do you say
I am uh you know I realized this morning
when I was washing the dishes I just
come from the gym and I did my upper
body actually ran into somebody this
past weekend I would say dude I always
see at the gym that was he he's like
you're always doing legs that made me
feel good you know being a child of the
80s
you never did your legs it was just all
about the upper body right just building
yourself up from the waist up like a
house of [ __ ] cards and all it took
was one leg sweep one photo putting up
[ __ ] three fifteen four times dude
one leg sleep what does land on your
side separate your shoulder right just
covering up your skinny little legs
trying to [ __ ] kick the guy off you
in some [ __ ] parking lot that they
put a tent over so they could sell some
bud light's with lime in it remember
those days you remember remember that
right we get [ __ ] hammered and then
the [ __ ] the red line would shut down
and we'd have to [ __ ] steal again
sorry I'm I'm pitching the sequel to
Good Will Hunting how soon before they
reboot that right I would say good will
this is a leather chair I'm not farting
profusely here was they gonna say yeah
the sequel to [ __ ] Good Will Hunting
alright we'll marry the chick there
Minnie Driver he marries her they have
four kids now that divorced because you
know just hugging Robin Williams doesn't
erase a childhood so eventually his
demons because he is who he is came out
the [ __ ] marriage ends now they got
four kids and the one that's most like
will doesn't get along with them you
know cuz they're so online
right and dad I don't know I don't know
where they somehow this ironman there so
they'll actually promote the movie or
[ __ ] one of one of those [ __ ]
goddamn when is that chicken and this
there's like no end in sight to those
[ __ ] movies right it's like becoming
incestuous now now they like they're
doing like the Ocean's eleven of like
superhero movies these [ __ ] poor
actors man you know back in the day used
to dream of getting a roller plane this
a plate of that now everybody that just
everybody's selling it do it I just if I
could just be if I could just be
lightning man I could get a bungalow in
[ __ ] Oxnard
but who knows congratulations to
Liverpool they won I missed the game
yesterday they won two to one I was
hoping they went to nothing so I could
say to nil it sound like I know what I'm
talking about as far as I know there's
still one point behind the [ __ ] Man
City [ __ ] doll that Middle Eastern
money you want your money clean from a
pure nation a pure part of the world
like the United States of America that's
right because we're always on the right
side of the ball if there's any comedian
out there listening right now if you
want to get laughs when you go overseas
just start reciting our propaganda you
don't even need a setup or anything and
people just start laughing
Bacon's afraid of people just they just
laugh all right the standings what do we
got here first place by two points oh my
god you got to be [ __ ] in the wait wait
wait before I get excited is it though
is this the latest one it is are you
[ __ ] kidding me what happened what
happened a man city with their
never-ending oil money what happened I
the old breakfast buffet got you the
Yanks came in
they're big families in that big bag of
cash whoa
all right I love it I love money against
money because I'm a capitalist I want to
see how this is going down is there
anything better than watching these
giant hardware stores just putting each
other out of business I can't get enough
of it
just [ __ ] throw it down like
bloodsport own trophy we'll be the ones
that sell all the how much no one who
said I am and this part of the region
it's part of the world and as we say
show or sad you want to build something
we've ruined all the Alison sorry
anyway supplying ahead here this morning
after I went to the gym did my legs
yesterday my pasty spindle e legs that
just never seemed to want to get any
bigger but I have to do them to keep my
sciatic nerve issue at bay because what
happened after years is driving myself
stick gigs right playing every [ __ ]
from here to [ __ ] Chilkoot Charlie's
I did them all white privilege on
hashtag not so much I hate when white
people because they actually had to work
for what they wanted in life think that
they're not privileged my dad didn't
have a yacht therefore you need to look
it up doesn't mean you don't have to
work it just means that no point was
your skin color a detriment if anything
it was a positive that's not true I was
one of the people doesn't get picked up
go to college I like when white people
talk about affirmative action too when
like nine black kids get in and they say
that's why they weren't able to join the
other 30,000 white kids at the
University oh that's why that that's
what it was that's what held you back
you know you couldn't get into the upper
[ __ ] 92% of white people if you were
in the lower 8% and now I'm supposed to
feel bad for you
snowflake snowflake little snowflake
sorry um anyway so I was doing the
dishes and I wore a long-sleeve shirt
because it gets a little cool out here
in the desert in the morning so I wore a
long-sleeve workout shirt so I didn't
want to get any water my sleeves [ __ ]
gross something out the same way when I
put lotion on I take my wedding ring off
because I don't like what it gets
underneath the ring it [ __ ] grosses
me out so I take off my shirt I'm
standing there shirtless watching
relaxed ladies I'm standing there
shirtless washing dishes the way I wish
my wife would and it was reminded me of
every joke that I heard a bunch of
comics do back in the day when they were
talking about cops going like is there a
rule that when you get arrested you have
to not be wearing a shirt then never
wearing a shirt and it was [ __ ] true
but it finally dawned on me today
probably that was because a lot of them
couldn't afford air conditioning you
know and God knows you know they want to
get a lot of seasons when they first did
cops they're like well how many how can
you get five seasons out of this it's
like well we're mainly going to shoot in
Florida and down south and everybody
knows gets hot down there hotter than
junebug [ __ ] a lamp on I'm gonna cook
and do dye morning so that's my theory
with the no shirt thing I also think
it's a [ __ ] it's something that's done
by people that go in and out of jail
that's just part of the culture it's you
know you don't wear a shirt the same way
like you know the people that go to like
the [ __ ] Ivy League schools you got
away like the [ __ ] that douche outfit
whatever the [ __ ] you call that the
khaki pants with the [ __ ] loafers
there's that [ __ ] thing that you know
it's actually one of my favorite looks
when the white person steers into being
white rather than being ashamed of it
you know what I mean or trying to put on
a blue collar jacket you know cuz every
once every two days you go out walk down
to the [ __ ] mailbox to get your
[ __ ] mail you know I like people that
[ __ ] stare into it
you know what does that look called it's
like I can't I ever got vague that that
thing on Instagram that don't be a bread
I love the way those kids dress you know
the parents had money and now they know
they're getting it and they're not
ashamed of it
they don't have one ounce of guilt and
they're just like listen my daddy
polluted all the rivers and when I take
over I'm going after the oceans you know
you gotta respect it's my goal in that
there'll be no more polar bears by the
time I'm done running my daddy's company
I enjoy that I like that just a little
bit of honesty that's all you know just
be who the [ __ ] you are all right
I watched the f1 yesterday did anybody
see the first race of the year down on
Australia Australian Grand Prix the
local favourite Daniel Ricciardo where
is he from Perth resting place of the
great born Scott and he's with the
Renault team this year who by the way I
love the look of their cars the yellow
and the black that looks cool as hell
granted I'm a Bruins fan so I don't know
maybe that's what it is but I think
those cars will cool his [ __ ] this poor
bastard Daniel Ricciardo
a [ __ ] the race just starts he barely
goes on the grass and the front end of
his car [ __ ] blows up his front wing
hit something in the whole front of the
car look at it [ __ ] exploded so
here's my question why do they have
bumpy grass like that day it wasn't they
hit a tree stump or something
especially right there near the start
somebody always goes off the grass a
little bit [ __ ] up his car and then he
was like a layette go and changed the
nose after the front the first lap and
then he's down a lap and then his car
just [ __ ] the bed and it's just like he
left Red Bull for this I don't know
anyways I'm basically I root for Daniel
Ricciardo for some reason I root for
Ferrari knowing that they're just not
going to get it done I root for the Hass
team because that's the American team
did alright yesterday if you think you
know one out of two people finishing is
good but you know we did come in
what's-his-face
Magnusson came in sixth place eight big
points right what's-his-face it was the
other driver we got there what the
hell's his name Roman Grosjean yeah he
didn't finish where the [ __ ] were the
Ferraris the Ferraris were in fourth and
fifth max Verstappen who's basically I
think gonna be the next Lewis Hamilton
if he could get a better ride because
for whatever [ __ ] reason those Red
Bull cars you know that they they can
[ __ ] with the Ferraris but not with the
Mercedes so 1 & 2 is Valtteri Bottas and
Lewis Hamilton I'm trying you know
I I love greatness but I just can't get
into the fact how Lewis Hamilton things
felt Airy botas should basically be his
[ __ ] right both sides had this amazing
start Lewis had the pole he [ __ ] blows
by him in the first turn and then he
just pulled away for the rest of the
goddamn race Lewis was having his issues
and whenever that happens he always acts
like a baby
he started bitching that Valtteri was
too far in front of him wasn't helping
him out it's like just a [ __ ] you know
what he just he reminds me of a couple
of comedians and actors that I've worked
with like where the whole [ __ ] scene
the whole show it's about them alright
and if overall what happened was good
but they're part of it wasn't as good as
they'd like they have a little [ __ ]
hissy fit maybe that's why he's [ __ ]
great cuz he is great and I would never
say that he wasn't but Jesus he always
had like I've seen like you know I've
seen Vettel not went in last year and
Kimi räikkönen was gonna win something
or he was out in front ever heard him
[ __ ] bitching about it he just
rear-ends people in front of him
[Laughter]
it's just bugging you know if Mercedes
is winning you're a team you took first
and second you're fine I know I know the
whole deal is the way he's wired that's
why he's so great but it's just like
it's such a [ __ ] it's such a chick
move you know what I mean like if you
have some [ __ ] you have to do that day
as a guy you go out and do it if your
wife's got a bunch of [ __ ] she just be
like I thought maybe you could come with
me we could maybe you have like a lunch
to eat drag you into it you wouldn't
know it but I still love the guy you
know I can never hate on [ __ ]
greatness the guy is [ __ ] great but
that part of him you know I guess we all
have that part of ourselves that maybe
we could all work on anyways I'm very
excited that's it's it's back f1 is back
you know it was cool they were like it's
been a hundred and twelve days that's
the last race and I was thinking like
well I haven't drank in 113 days old
freckles I took a day off right before
the last race of last year I'm almost a
third of the way in to breaking my
record of 367 days since I started
drinking man and what the first 15 years
of my life never had a drop I don't see
myself beating that streak anytime soon
so I think I'm gonna try to go until
June of next year so then I would do a
calendar year January to December and
then I would also do an entire birthday
like my entire time of being 51 I didn't
have a drop I think that would be cool
then I would gone for like a [ __ ]
year and seven months right and at that
point I have all the alcohol out of my
house and then I think what I do is I
don't drink in LA I don't drink at home
and when I go on the road one day out of
the I call in the road two weekends a
month and one day out of those things so
I'll be drinking two times a month 24
times a year okay whatever the [ __ ] you
gonna do I think that'd be all right you
know I got to figure out what the [ __ ]
gonna open for me
well my open is a [ __ ] and they're
crushing it now Paul virzi check out the
tour dates Joe bartnik we got to check
out puck off he's got a
the [ __ ] did he just have on there
Darren McCarty
he's doing the plot of the [ __ ] athl
Awards writing on that I just said I
won't a [ __ ] am I gonna have now you
know [ __ ] law heads down to San Diego
crushing it on the sports radio see this
is what happens when you don't bring
cupcakes on the road they move up into
the business so I'm just putting it out
there are you the funny guy at the
office do you think that you'd like to
be a stand-up comedian well why don't
you submit your tape to billboard.com
maybe you could play some chuckle hut do
15 minutes in front of a bunch of
animals before you bring up the freckled
prick who's closing out the show oh by
the way how about those Bruins huh
Conor McGregor showed up right I missed
the whole game that's why I course it
was [ __ ] exciting I missed the whole
goddamn game I came in right at the end
of the streak I watched two games where
they continued it and then they lost two
in a row and then I missed the next game
and they win it in overtime Brad
Marchand [ __ ] in overtime and that he
does the Conor McGregor celebration and
I missed the whole goddamn thing but you
know what I did see I did see the Maple
Leafs game who the [ __ ] were they
playing somebody who had like a big
big-time lead like a 5 to 2 lead and
they came back and wanted I know they
were in the st. Patrick's Day jerseys
what has happened to my short-term
memory it's out the window
I gotta start playing brain games again
who the [ __ ] were they playing
anyways I Toronto is my table if the
Bruins don't win it this year at
Toronto's my teeth that's who the [ __ ] I
root for and in the West I always root
for the st. Louis Blues those are the
two teams that have gone the longest
without winning the [ __ ] thing and I
don't know how much longer do you want
they're their fans to suffer which is
why I think it's [ __ ] when that was
an Antonio Brown whatever his [ __ ]
name is that wide receiver from from the
Steelers has a falling-out with his team
the Bills make a deal they're like all
right you're coming in it's just like
yeah no I'm not going there you guys
suck
then he goes to the [ __ ] Raiders it's
just like so what it builds fans
supposed to do I've never understood
that John Elway I'm not playing for the
Colts well then you're not playing the
NFL go to CFL you [ __ ] right Kobe Bryant
I'm not playing for the Charlotte
Hornets well enjoy Europe it's not how
it works I wanna go where I'm gonna have
a chance to win to me a bunch of [ __ ]
babies you know what I mean I guess I
understand
maybe the quarterback position just
because if you don't have an offensive
line that she's just gonna get right but
you're playing [ __ ] basketball Jesus
Christ you can't even touch anybody
anymore right and I can say this having
not played organized sports for 40 years
I know what it takes you know this is
just me bitching as a fan I was excited
to see the bills get an offensive weapon
there you know if you want to see a
bunch of grown men cry you wait to the
day the [ __ ] bills when when the
goddamn Superbowl
all right everyone the Red Sox finally
wanted everybody who's [ __ ] freaking
you wait till when the bills went these
people gonna run outside crying their
tears are gonna freeze on their face
because they live in Buffalo and they're
just gonna hug their neighbor right and
then they're gonna fall down and land on
that little heating thing that heats up
their [ __ ] engine in the morning and
it's gonna unplug in the next morning
it's not gonna [ __ ] start and they're
not gonna give a [ __ ] they're gonna get
mad for half a second then they go wait
a minute wait a minute they [ __ ] and
they won the Super Bowl now I I don't
give a [ __ ] anymore
anyway plowing ahead here what else am I
gonna do today I'm gonna go get I'm
getting three MRIs I'm finally gonna
finally see what's going on with my
shoulders and then my left knee that's
what I'm doing today and we'll fix my
both my shoulders and my knee and then
I'll probably have some sort of cancer
from all that radiates
see that's how it works everybody you
know it's one of the reasons why I love
Breaking Bad is every time they've made
a step forward they there was always a
price to pay and at best they were even
but they never really were they always
sank down a little bit lower you know it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense I'll tell
you everybody this world this world
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense to me
yeah this whole [ __ ] food thing and
booze thing here's something I finally
had an epiphany about being an adult in
addiction and being fat and [ __ ] all
of this [ __ ] that you try to avoid is no
one ever really tells you like the the
level of responsibility of when you go
out on your own just for yourself to not
[ __ ] the whole thing up I was sitting
there right I'm on the Instagram and one
of the people I follow he's in his 20s
right and he's filming like the night
out all right
it's drummer okay and everybody's
drinking everybody's dancing it just
keeps going and going and going and
going and going until like [ __ ] 4:00
in the morning and I understand that you
do that when you're at that age but
there is a part of me thinking like what
if I didn't do that not like I danced in
the street but you know what I mean I
was hooked in the street till like 4:00
in the [ __ ] morning what if I didn't
do that like how many more miles on this
engine what I have you know because like
right now I'll tell you my drug is eight
hours sleep honey
I don't just as far as like I was really
sitting there like trying to think how
I'm gonna explain that to my daughter
one day it's like all right you're going
off to college now you're gonna have
this ridiculous level of freedom I
remember the first time when I finally
[ __ ] moved out I remember I was in
New York City it was my first night
hanging out I was hanging out at the
comic strip
and it hit me it's like I don't have to
[ __ ] go home until I want to go home
I don't have to answer to [ __ ]
anybody and this big grin just broke out
on my face like Jesus Christ this is
[ __ ] amazing because of course I was
down there like Jesus Christ I moved
like two states away I don't [ __ ]
know anybody I'm in a railroad apartment
you know I just talked to Lucian rest
his soul he's like I already have an
ovoid good I have no need for you good
luck with your dream I'm ever just
sitting there at that bar and then but
then the epiphany was that Jesus Christ
I could [ __ ] do whatever I wanted and
[ __ ] me to check take a home this is
[ __ ] unbelievable and fortunately
during that time everybody that I was
hanging out with was either they didn't
drink or they they were already in AAA
and I've always just been you know I
just did what people around nobody
around me is drinking they want to go
out and go to a diner instead I would
just [ __ ] do that so I didn't drink a
lot in my 20s but somewhere in my 30s it
kind of went off the [ __ ] rails and I
wish I could go back if I can tell you
guys anything yet
don't bring the booze into the house
have it it's like literally why would
you bring cookies and cake and potato
chip into your house you're gonna become
a fat [ __ ] you bring booze into your
house you're gonna become a drunk
I'm not saying an alkie but it'll just
be something that you just [ __ ] do if
you like smoking a cigar don't buy a
humidor keep it I don't bring the devil
into your house keep them down the
[ __ ] Street you're getting out the
deal is cuz you'll sit there for 10
minutes being like I [ __ ] bet I'd love a
goddamn cigar or I'd love to go get a
drink and then you sit there and I got
to [ __ ] get dressed I got to get in
the car you know [ __ ] this I'll just you
know I'll just sit here and hang out but
the one thing I I have this really
fascinates me is now that I don't
I'm really not doing anything is getting
used to just being sober and I don't
just mean you know booze I mean then
also combining that with trying to eat
right because it's like at the end of
the night like I'm just used to being
ramped up having a couple of pops and
then when you quit boozing then that
becomes like food like eat something
sugary or eat something salty and you
know you know just [ __ ] get the RPMs
going in your body and the reality is
your body doesn't want to do that it
just wants to be [ __ ] idling chilling
out saving it stuff for when you got to
run from an earthquake a fire or some
guy with an axe essentially and I don't
know I feel like I need to take you know
that [ __ ] that you put in your gas tank
to clean out your engine but then you
get nervous am I gonna move the clots
around I feel like I gotta [ __ ] do
that man
so now my big thing is like I've been
cooking at home and last night I asked
for the first time and forever
I made like a full meal like two sides
in a and I ate a little steak so I made
this little steak I had some steamed
broccoli and then I had the potatoes
right garlic was a little bit of
rosemary a little bit of salt and pepper
and some butter oh my god they were
[ __ ] delicious that was basically
that was the highlight of my night was
those mashed potatoes but I'm gonna
[ __ ] I'm trying to revamp my whole
lifestyle here so when I returned to
drinking which I will at some point I
just want to make sure that I do it in a
like the way I drink soda or pop few
people in the Midwest like a cage-like
if I have like a bomb out it's usually
back east if I'm having a pizza then I
would always get a coke and even then I
could never really [ __ ] I could never
really finish it if I'm just having a
bad meal
I'll have like a Coke or something like
that if I could just do that with booze
you know there's [ __ ] people they can
just have a a glass of wine mmm that was
delicious
that complimented my meal right they
don't sit there like a pirate [ __ ]
bite the cork off it anyway I did a I
did a gig at the American Legion I got
to open for Ron White I worked with Joe
DeRosa and it's not the guy Alex I
didn't get his last name he's [ __ ]
hilarious
and in John sites we had a [ __ ] great
time and afterwards you know we smoke
some cigars and stuff and there was a
couple buddies of mine they showed up
and one of them showed up he had bought
a [ __ ] one of those new Indian
motorcycles the one that looks like the
Harley Road King [ __ ] dude I would love
one of those 2-tone he had black with
the green man that thing was [ __ ]
sick and and all those guys on those big
bites they always go it's like riding a
Cadillac you know it's getting it's got
the three lights people can see man
that's that's one of those [ __ ]
that'll remain the dad fantasy it's like
if I didn't have a kid if I didn't if I
wasn't living for somebody else now my
god I would [ __ ] get one of those I
would take it out Sunday mornings right
it's drive down the [ __ ] Street my
freckled arms out you know feeling like
I'm in a motorcycle gang what I really
never killed anybody pay my taxes
quarterly I blocked that part out right
drive down the street I would [ __ ]
love one of those I love those bikes I
love I love those big ones with the the
white-walled tires and [ __ ] like that
like I love a Harley Road King without
the bags on it I just think that that is
just one of the [ __ ] coolest looking
bikes ever who knows my daughter
graduates high school goes off to
college maybe I'll do it then I'll be
like my late 60s
I'll get one of those that's right
around the time when you get that three
wheeler
[ __ ] motorcycle you know which I
would think in a lot of ways could be a
little bit more dangerous all of a
sudden you kind of had to like I don't
know
like how does that work if somebody cuts
out in front of you and you got to lay
it down you can't lay it down what do
you do
you just [ __ ] t-bone the guy and go
flying over the [ __ ] I don't know
there's got to be some sort of Robocop
type thing that they can put on can you
buy one of those MotoGP suits with like
the [ __ ] airbag in it and [ __ ] they
don't have an airbag for your head
that's the problem
wait a second MotoGP riding suit for
sale this thing will be like five grand
if they do well there's one for 478
dollars so you know that's not it I
prefer to put a airbag in there with
airbag and then you're gonna like that
would the thing is like that's like
hooked on to the bike come on you
[ __ ] [ __ ] shop race shop race suits
with airbags all right Amazon there's
one for a thousand bucks there's one for
for 1,500 bucks all right this sounds
about right
you know the MotoGP ones if you actually
got one of those it's like [ __ ] three
grand
but is it thing you can have one of
those and it's not going to help you if
someone an SUV runs you over yeah in
another life I would have had kids
younger and then I would have lived in
the middle of nowhere and I would have
had one oh well speaking of motorcycles
motorcycle Japanese and Italian
motorcycles I don't have any advertising
this week
all right Japanese and Italian
motorcycles hey Bill on your March 14th
podcast you wondered why Japanese and
Italian companies make better
motorcycles that's not what all right
had a little glitch there ran out of
batteries
ran out of batteries getting back to
what I was saying I didn't say that you
guys make better motorcycles you just
make the fast ones like why don't mean
why does it Honda Indian or somebody
like that make a fast one
one explanation I've heard they're
probably better but as an American I
can't [ __ ] say that one explanation I
heard is that after World War two
engineers and designers for the axis
military industrial complex were forced
to find civilian and non-military work
some of the brightest smartest engineers
in those countries ended up in
automotive motorcycles and electronics
Honda Yamaha
Sony Ferrari Lamborghini Ducati or Dew
caddy as they say in England in
particular or at least the announcer
does in particular aeronautical
engineers who had designed fighter
planes found success applying their
knowledge to motorcycle jassi's designed
because many of the forces acting on a
plane's fuselage is similar to the
forces on a motorcycle leaned over going
through a turn that's fascinating
also because of rationing in the years
following World War two engineers and
former Axis countries had to figure out
how to design and manufacture with less
raw material like steel or aluminum you
can see how efficiently engineered
German Italian and Japanese engines are
compared to a chunky harley-davidson
motorcycle just post ride chat I've
heard over the years but I thought you
might find it interesting thanks for
making me laugh and making your podcast
that is really interesting something
else is that just the sheer amount of
space that we have over here you know
that it we're not driving down these
little streets that you used to ride a
[ __ ] horse and buggy around and that
everything needs to be really the cars
motorcycles got to be quick and nimble
and all of that you could just [ __ ]
you know if you look at our cars it's
the same thing it's all about zero to 60
in a straight line because for the most
part there's not a lot of turns and [ __ ]
you know that we're going to be taking
so I think part of it is also that but I
really find
interesting that just through you know a
loss comes a win like that that's
usually what happens that reminds me I
was watching that Joe Rogan podcast with
Mike Tyson and he was alluding to the
fact and a lot of boxers have that like
you know boxing is basically that
there's never been like a rich kid that
I can think of that just you know came
from a great background everything just
goes in and does that like it's it's for
somebody that just came from nothing and
you literally literally fighting your
way out of it
that would be [ __ ] hilarious though
if one of those don't be a brad kids
actually came you know you know one of
those kids that accidentally kills his
girlfriend while having rough sex
remember those [ __ ] billionaire boy
club [ __ ] lunatics from the 80s if
one of him he came in and if he just
steered into it like a great wrestling
he'll like when he did his interviews he
had his boat shoes with no socks on and
khaki pants he's just his old thing is
even though he came up with all that
money and [ __ ] he's just like a complete
[ __ ] sociopath and then goes in and
like his nickname should just be staring
into all of that [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
would be would be like Brad the trust
fund kid you know [ __ ] van something
or other
as always the [ __ ] rich white people
names right I missed that I missed the
robber baron being famous you know all
right I'd missed it the first time but
like JP Morgan Wow
Andrew Carnegie not van de belts that
just all became a corporation I think
that that's why they did it they became
a corporation so then they their names
wouldn't be out there so now it's like
can you believe what a labert and raw
egg you believe what would Monsanto you
don't have one [ __ ] name you know
just as far as barroom chatter goes I'm
sure if he actually took the time to
care enough to research it you'd know
her name all right I think I was kind of
[ __ ]
myself by the end there all right what
else do we got here
marginal tax rate hey Bill I'm listening
to a recent podcast where you talk about
a o'seas plan to tax people at a higher
rate the marginal tax rate kicks in
after someone earns their first ten
million dollars after that the income is
taxed at seventy percent do [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that
that doesn't touch people who create
startups yeah it does when they turn
around and sell it for [ __ ] tens of
millions of dollars of course it does
most Khomeini's don't make anything
close to that you don't even know what
comedians make that's not [ __ ] true
comedians are crushing it right now and
secondly what I [ __ ] hate about all of
this [ __ ] is everybody's going to ignore
the reason why we're broke we're broke
because we're fighting this never-ending
[ __ ] war that is lining the pockets
of above [ __ ] a half a dozen to a
dozen corporations and it's completely
bankrupted this [ __ ] country so
rather than take those people to task
who pay all the [ __ ] politicians now
you're gonna go after regular [ __ ]
citizens and we're gonna have to pay the
tab go [ __ ] yourself dude seventy
percent tax on anything is [ __ ]
criminal criminal to take more than half
somebody is doing that work you don't
get more than half of that go [ __ ]
yourself those politicians need to grow
a [ __ ] dick and some [ __ ] balls
and stand up to those corporations that
they're [ __ ] blowing that's the
solution [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] people
who sit there and they demonize anybody
any individual that went out and went
after a dream and made it and then they
have to turn around and subsidize your
[ __ ] life go [ __ ] yourself you really
want to take down the rich go after
these [ __ ] corporations that have all
their money in offshore [ __ ] accounts
kick him out of the [ __ ] country and
stop buying this [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
punish some person because they started
Dollar Shave Club in their [ __ ]
dormitory now all of a sudden they got
to give 70% of it away
you know what you sound like you sound
like somebody who's never gonna make ten
million dollars in their life oh my god
that drives me up the [ __ ] wall and
that's the genius once again of
corporations is there's no name there's
no face to it
but you can do it with individuals so
now they're gonna get punished anyway so
let me finish this after the income it
it's tax seventy percent that doesn't
touch people who created startups that's
just a statement that you pulled out of
your ass most comedians don't make
anything close to that that's pulled out
of your ass that's pulled out of your
Epps I've seen like the top [ __ ]
earning comedians that Forbes [ __ ]
lists they're all over 10 million some
of them making twenty million dollars
they're supposed to give 70 percent of
over ten million away anyways the most
skilled brain surgeons don't make that
much the people making more than ten
million a year are closed with extremely
high concentrations of wealth no they're
not this is this what this is what
you're doing dude what you're doing is
you're creating this cartoon character
of a rich person the same way female
comics created a cartoon character of a
white male comedian where he just goes
down to the club and the club owner goes
what are your dreams how many doors can
I open for you nobody wants to see that
it's [ __ ] work I can't even I can't
even read the [ __ ] rest of this
that's like that person going someone
who makes ten million dollars a year it
doesn't work any harder than someone who
makes twenty thousand dollars a year
it's like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about if you work for yourself I don't
care what the [ __ ] you make a year you
it never ends
it's it's seven days a week 365 you're
working your [ __ ] ass off anyways
collecting it at a rate that is
unnecessary for unhuman any human on
earth being able to start from nothing
is what America merica great yeah you're
gonna yank all these people back down
again those people also will make that
they create a bunch of [ __ ] jobs
there's a way to run your country your
company right anyways this is being able
to start from nothing is what makes a
mess
great and if anything a higher tax rate
enables more Americans to follow their
dreams that is complete [ __ ] because
what you're gonna do is just yank your
fellow [ __ ] country mint down to the
ground none of this [ __ ] you're not
gonna get to go out to these [ __ ]
corporations there and all these
super-rich people their money's already
out of the country they got it running
through [ __ ] 20 different islands and
that's 20 different [ __ ] mountains of
red tape that the IRS is not going to
take their time to go through and that's
why they're gonna go after just regular
[ __ ] people because we're standing
here with that [ __ ] pants down
allowing people to hoard massive amounts
of wealth only shrinks the middle class
creating larger conglomerates and pushes
us further towards a horrible dystopia
where everything is commercialized well
first of all dude you're about 40
[ __ ] years too late at that party all
right
and all your all your all these [ __ ]
tax things are gonna do they're not
gonna [ __ ] with any corporation they
[ __ ] brush the IRS off their shoulder
like it's a [ __ ] net all you're gonna
do is you're gonna go after new money
somebody went out and started something
who the [ __ ] are you to say how much
money anybody can [ __ ] make because
you don't have an idea that will enable
you to make ten million dollars somebody
else to [ __ ] subsidize your life and
you're gonna ignore the [ __ ] elephant
in the room and you're just gonna go
after the [ __ ] individual go [ __ ]
yourself go [ __ ] yourself I didn't want
to [ __ ] hear this this is this
[ __ ] [ __ ] that that [ __ ] chick
is talking about there that everybody's
all high-and-mighty on she's talking
about individuals she's not gonna go out
after the corporations that she's gonna
go out and give speeches to after she's
done with her political career to the
tune of 300 [ __ ] grand a night just
like the [ __ ] Obamas but everybody's
gonna sit there and act like it's only
the bushes in the Trump's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] Obamas just like the Clintons
are lining their pockets with that same
[ __ ] corporate money that is never
gonna be [ __ ] with and they're just
they're gonna go after stand-up comics
people that start apps people who start
Dollar Shave Club that who the
that's who the [ __ ] is gonna get yanked
down and you sat down you in every we've
all sat back support the troops support
the troops he can't [ __ ] speak out
against the war and you literally watch
them bankrupt this [ __ ] country and
every year in August we're like we don't
have any more money we don't have any
money
what's the solution do we go after the
[ __ ] banks do we go after the
corporation's no we just raised the
level of debt that this country is going
to accept and now we're gonna turn
around and we're gonna make sure that no
individual who doesn't [ __ ] pour
water in the [ __ ] rivers and put up
for water poor [ __ ] their chemicals
and the goddamn rivers and all I should
just let all of those [ __ ] people
all of those [ __ ] who [ __ ] polluted
your [ __ ] goddamn food supply to the
point you got girls getting their
[ __ ] periods at nine years old and a
kid can grow a [ __ ] full beard by the
time he's 10 ignore all of that [ __ ] and
just sit there and be like I don't think
you need to make 10 million does go [ __ ]
yourself you know what buddy I hope you
make 10 million dollars and I hope you
get to keep more than goddamn [ __ ]
30% of it cuz you earned it you should
have to pay because you [ __ ] because
of what cuz you earn too much [ __ ]
money listen I'm gonna tell you
something right now
if these corporations were paying their
fair [ __ ] share I wouldn't have a
problem with this and you if you wanted
to cap it at 10 million dollars
fine but that's not what the [ __ ] you
gonna do all right I got heated their
[ __ ] goddamn stupid ass [ __ ]
morons out there with you why don't you
read up on what the [ __ ] it takes why
don't you read up on what it takes to
[ __ ] go from not having anything to
[ __ ] get in there why don't you fetch
me figure out how hard you have to
[ __ ] work to even get anywhere close
to half of that [ __ ] money how
[ __ ] strong you have to be mentally
how much [ __ ] you have to get put
through as you [ __ ] watch and other
people around you that you started out
with watching them slowly go crazy
watching them kill themselves and all of
this other [ __ ] [ __ ] and then turn a
complete blind eye to
can banks and corporations and all of
these [ __ ] [ __ ] let yeah let's go
after people make them moans yeah yeah
[ __ ] nationwide drug epidemic let's
just completely ignore all the [ __ ]
pharmaceutical companies that's fine
that's fine let's just go after Joe Blow
who [ __ ] worked his [ __ ] balls off
you know who the [ __ ] are you to say
what the [ __ ] just a certain segment of
people are gonna [ __ ] make and you're
gonna ignore all those goddamn
corporations and don't even [ __ ] tell
me the Hoku after them to how they run
the foot they run all of these [ __ ]
politicians every one of them is on
their [ __ ] knees blowing them in
occasionally when you got a guy like
Bernie Sanders who actually wants to
stand up to those [ __ ] what do they do
they [ __ ] box him out and they give
him no coverage whatsoever and then what
do they do they go with the [ __ ] made
man the Hillary Clinton right and then
she loses to this orange headed [ __ ] and
now we're dealing with this [ __ ] jesus
[ __ ] christ all right
mother-in-law was some messed up
passive-aggressive behavior all right I
have to end this podcast soon cuz I got
to go [ __ ] oh my god nobody who's
making who's not making ten million
dollars should [ __ ] be telling
somebody what they should be fun my
saying what the [ __ ] you should be
paying I want to hear what your [ __ ]
ideas that I'm gonna bet that if I ever
get over ten million I'm gonna be [ __ ]
subsidizing what you could sit on your
[ __ ] ass and not do anything and have
a [ __ ] nine-to-five job and it'll be
over right at [ __ ] five o'clock on
Friday and you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want for the rest of your
[ __ ] weekend well with poor people
who [ __ ] a running companies got to
figure out through the weekend how to
keep that thing afloat so you still have
your [ __ ] job then on top of that
they're supposed to get 70% of their
money over ten million to you so you can
get another [ __ ] beanbag chair go
[ __ ] yourself
unbelievably
haven't we definitely shown that just
giving people [ __ ] money doesn't do
anything there really is that fantasy
that you know if you give people [ __ ]
opportunity you know they're gonna make
something to themselves not true that's
only half the recipe that's like if you
get a bag of sugar you can make a pie no
you can't you need [ __ ] eggs you need
all kinds of other [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody
has to have the drive they have the
vision and they got to be strong enough
that when they keep getting a dick
knocking the dirt to keep [ __ ]
getting up and staying positive and not
letting his [ __ ] business eat you up
I had a [ __ ] text from a buddy of
mine last night I couldn't believe I
haven't talked in a while how [ __ ]
negative he got and I'm trying to find a
nice way say dude don't let this
business get to you don't let him put
the [ __ ] pilot light out because when
they do you [ __ ] done all right I
never had to have that [ __ ] talk when
I was unloading trucks working in a
warehouse I don't know listen I am all
for [ __ ] paying taxes and all of that
[ __ ] if they would actually spend it on
[ __ ] the public schools if they would
pay if they would actually spend it on
trying to get people tax breaks to
[ __ ] keep industry in this goddamn
country and they haven't everybody who's
thought about themselves and they've
sent the thing out the [ __ ] window so
now what's gonna happen is you're gonna
start going after the individual and
somehow demonize somebody that actually
went after dreaming as corrupt as his
funk country has actually got somewhere
you're now gonna [ __ ] yank his
[ __ ] pants down the [ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I think for you to make a statement like
that at some point your life you should
you should actually have made over ten
million dollars a [ __ ] year so maybe
you'd have a little bit of empathy you
could actually speak with some sort of
[ __ ] knowledge instead of sitting
there playing the goddamn victim all
right if you want to start a [ __ ]
revolution and go after banks and
corporations I'm [ __ ] all for it if
you want to start yanking other [ __ ]
your own fellow countrymen have done
nothing wrong down by their [ __ ]
ankles because they had the balls to go
after something it [ __ ] actually
become successful and then you're gonna
decide how successful they need
to be because these people are [ __ ]
honest enough to actually report their
goddamn income they meanwhile you got
the [ __ ] [ __ ] who owns the goddamn
corporation after it's gone through 20
[ __ ] goddamn Islands is now getting a
loan from the last [ __ ] Island an
interest-free tax-free [ __ ] loan his
money comes back to him in the form of a
[ __ ] loan and then that phantom
[ __ ] corporation forgives the loan
and the guys paying zero how about that
buddy how about that yeah but let's
ignore corporations that keep us in wars
that bleed this country die dry and
let's go after the Dollar Shave Club guy
there you go there you go let's go after
the guys who started barstool sports yes
they're the they're the [ __ ] problem
motivated [ __ ] people who started
from nothing and in and hit the mother
lode I don't know Jesus Christ that was
[ __ ] ten minutes of my life I'll
never get back
alright mother-in-law was some messed up
passive-aggressive behavior dear bill my
boyfriend's mother is probably the most
passive-aggressive piece of [ __ ] you
ever met in your life by the way I still
have to talk about this the [ __ ]
level of money that I'm making I'm lucky
if I get to keep 1/3 of it and on paper
I'm not paying 70% tag you wait til that
[ __ ] thing kicks in and if you think
they're gonna stop at ten million and
then it's gonna be well at 5 million
shouldn't they pay this at 1 million
shouldn't they pay this any check that I
get any [ __ ] check that I get I just
I just I take 70% already and throw it
out the [ __ ] window with Commission's
expenses and then the taxes that I pay
that's why people [ __ ] go broke they
go out and they get a million dollars
and they think they have a million
dollars it's like you don't you have
about 300 75 grand if you're lucky
that's what a million dollars is before
you're gonna implement this [ __ ]
kind of a [ __ ] Americans [ __ ] it
is for pulling down another regular guy
who was you yeah what why not get
inspired by that person no you should
give some of your money that you made
back to me [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
oh my god why doesn't everybody get to
play a down of NFL football just because
their NFL dream didn't make it right why
don't you just let him do that dear bill
my boyfriend's mother is probably the
most passive-aggressive piece of [ __ ]
you ever met in your life she's still
relatively young in her early 50s and
acts like a college kid around her
friends oh boy that's probably more
annoying than the last 12 minutes of
this podcast you just know that she was
a sorority bully when she was younger
and now she treats her family very
passive aggressively Wow for example
when she came over for dinner to our
house recently we asked if she could
remove her shoes as we don't appreciate
the filth from the street infecting our
floors this slided her from the get-go
and then she went to the bathroom and
deliberately left skid marks on the
toilet and came out and not announcing
to the room that we should clean it
regularly to prevent that from happening
oh my god I know that sounds crazy but
this is the same person who also made a
big deal about how somebody should get
tested for an STD because my oh saying
how I should get test for an STD because
my last boyfriend had an uncircumcised
penis please let me know what you would
do to put her in her place once and for
all
oh this is a tough one this is family a
family the family Becky's mother-in-law
messed up passive-aggressive behavior
but you're calling it your boyfriend
yeah you gotta nip this in the bud
before you even [ __ ] the bud whatever
the [ __ ] you say nip it in the bud
before before this goes any [ __ ]
further you don't want to marry into
that and if you do marry into it you got
to set up boundaries his deal I I would
just I would say something to your
boyfriend and what I would do that's
probably not gonna work you know what I
would do I would just say I don't
appreciate that comment and if you have
to have a fight with her I have a fight
with her and just say listen you're
coming over my house and these are my
rules if you don't like it don't come
over here and if she has a [ __ ]
problem with that your boyfriend has a
problem with that [ __ ] the both of them
[ __ ] the both of them all right yeah
there's no reason for you to be walking
around on eggshells where you live [ __ ]
this [ __ ] person and you'll basically
show your future mother-in-law who you
are and your boyfriend who you are and
you know whoever has a problem with it
can go [ __ ] themselves even come over
didn't leave skid marks in my toilet and
say somebody should clean that you
should have grabbed her by the back of
her [ __ ] neck and the seat of her
pants and thrown around bouncers style
right out of your [ __ ] house the [ __ ]
out of my house clean up my [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of my house that's an easy one
that's as easy as the 10 million dollars
a year thing there I'm open to its
hilarious sale I'm open to more debate
on that seven yeah I'll talk to somebody
who will actually talk about
corporations and banks if you want to
talk about that first and what you plan
to do with them then I will listen to
your [ __ ] over ten million dollars
and I I don't make anywhere near that
but like I plan to I'm building a
company I plan on that now I don't plan
on [ __ ] working my ass off so then I
can just go give it to a bunch of
corrupt [ __ ] who aren't gonna give it
to you they're not gonna give it to you
they're gonna give it in the form of
contra
to peek to people at big construction
companies to build more luxury high-rise
apartments they're gonna give them the
kickback [ __ ] money and they're gonna
charge way more money for the [ __ ]
materials all of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
government [ __ ] jobs building roads
and all of that that's where it's gonna
go it's not gonna go back to the kids
it's not gonna go back to the schools
and it's not gonna go to you it isn't it
never does cuz they're all [ __ ]
corrupt so if you want to talk about how
to somehow pay politicians more money so
they don't so they have [ __ ] you money
so they they don't have to [ __ ] sit
there and suck the dicks of these
corporations of these banks then maybe
we could try to [ __ ] have as honest a
companies you country as you could
possibly have which is impossible
because people [ __ ] on socialism they
[ __ ] on communism the [ __ ] on capitalism
none of them work none of them work
because human beings are inherently
flood alright so there you go that's my
uninformed [ __ ] for the [ __ ] day
god bless all you I got some [ __ ] to do
I know the podcast was a little bit
short but you're probably sick of me
after I was on my tree stump there for
[ __ ] 12 minutes alright god bless all
yeah I hope your dreams come true and I
hope when you go out and you make the
money that you earned some cut doesn't
come in and take 70% of it alright see
you Thursday